okay so you can see this thing is
growing now I want to know how much I
get after 30 years right I could do this
30 times but it's taking forever
right it's literally like you know
you're just punching in the buttons
takes a long time so I want a faster way
or what a faster way he's the way I'm
gonna introduce it okay have a look at
this here we're doing two steps each
time we're going principal interest
addemup then you do interest in the atom
up again interest and up again I want to
go directly from one line to another
from this line to this line then from
this line to this line I want to go from
p0 to p1 to p2 all the way to p3 so I
want to skip a whole bunch of steps how
do I do it okay well I want you to write
down these numbers for me okay let's put
in a little bit the table so I'll go P
naught is 5,000 p1 is 5,300 p2 and we've
gone up to p3
okay now once you have a look at these
numbers how are they getting bigger
getting bigger each time and is there a
way we can do this faster okay well go
from here here I multiplied the point oh
six and then I added the original back
right yeah yeah from here to here right
I'm multiplying by one point oh six can
you see that get you kicked and chicken
the one represents the original number
and the point of six represents the the
interest that gets added on exactly
right if I do it again from here to here
I'm just doing it five 1.06 again
this one what does that mean reserved
the principle what does the point oh six
represent the new interest every time
right okay so therefore if we wanted to
get turn p4 rather than just work out
the interest separately and then go to
the next step right
I can just multiply by you know this
part which is the original principal and
this part which is the interest so can
we multiply this by 1.06 what do you get
let me check it can I get out my
calculator and work it out faster than
you can five nine five five and eight
says yeah are too fast for me yeah what
you got six three one two three three
eight three eight four eight so three
eight that's what it would round to okay
sorry that's a really messy six it's
thought of as a fun it does just bad
number okay they go so this thing's
growing and it's growing faster its
compounding okay now I don't want paid
for or even five six seven or eight I
want to know what happens after 30 years
so just like I did here I could do all
these steps I could multiply by 1.06 and
1.6 always again and again and again ah
but in number skills you learn how to do
this all in one hit rather than doing it
one at a time how do I write this in a
faster way wait what's that
we're on the right track it does have to
do with this anyone else got another
idea
yeah okay so we could do this right he's
that way you got the 31 put it you can
say 1.06 the x thing ah but stop see
that time stain that's exactly the same
as simple interest right we don't
actually want to multiply by 30 that'll
still do it the same way as before each
time you'll get the same amount okay I'm
not gonna be times 30 and actually that
division making smaller wouldn't it we
want things get bigger it's actually ^
can you see that let me see if I can
write this part out again you know this
bit here that's 5,000 the original
amount right x 1.06 well I don't have to
calculate what that number is I can just
do it x 1.06 again but we have shorthand
for that which is the index notation
right that's 5,000 times 1.06 squared or
5,000 times 1.06 what would be next
kids right 5,000 1.06 to the four so i
find x well so I know multiply raise it
to the power of 35 that's what I'm gonna
get okay
No hold on now hold on a second
I don't just want that number on its own
I want that multiplied by my principal
that's how I got all these numbers so
multiply by 5,000 and what do you get
should be a pretty big number
all right eight is that right yeah
no no sense after that is it enough
can we verify that the zero no it's got
the same result 5,000 times 1.06 ^ do
you no one else working up there's
something else there's other bits on
there I didn't expect it to be such a
round number yeah okay so going from one
step to the next
okay all the way down me this is what's
going on okay how do I get fifty three
hundred went to three hundred come from
yeah that's right then what represents
the original principal one one of the
principal and the point oh six
represents six percent of at the
interest so going from here to here you
multiply by that that gives you the new
amount and then you do it again every
year that's what you do so I'm gonna do
it 30 times this is what does that
surprise you have a look at the number
how does it compare to our original this
just this is what I originally go to the
end that's more than double its double
that's amazing okay
so that's why co-managers is so much
better yeah yeah yes please okay
so let's pull this together yeah yes you
made you estimate yeah you see it now is
it okay hey no joke by the way can I
just say like it's so important to try
and explain something cuz often you
think you understand something and then
you start to explain to someone else and
you're like wait nevermind I have no
idea who told you all right but you
don't know that until you try and
explain it
okay so let's summarize let's so much
I'm gonna give you a new formula okay so
our channel song okay this is a simple
interest formula okay simple interest I
am going to give you a new formula a
compound interest formula okay so you
want to put this in big colorful letters
right compound interest formula
okay sir here's what it works out
firstly this compound interest for ER
hey Tom I would be surprised if you got
up no no like seriously if anyone gets
up and starts explaining someone some
you know and what everyone's listening
you know it's just why did I do this yep
yeah let's now this formula gives you
interest rate this formula is
interesting but this formula that we've
been developing it doesn't give you just
the interest it actually gives you what
the whole bank account is worth the
whole amount that you have after one or
two or three years not just how much
interest you've got okay so therefore it
doesn't start off I equals it starts off
a equals a for mounts now after that the
pieces you get on the right hand side
are exactly the same as these pieces but
they are arranged differently I'll show
you you still start with the pink the
principle okay but what you multiply it
by is not the rate it's one plus the
race okay can you see here see this 6%
that's where it is right so this is 1
plus 6% 1 plus 0.06 which is one point
it seems now every year you multiply it
by that 1.06 about one plus the interest
rate
remember again however many times once
or twice or three times all 30 times
so what goes up here is the end the
number of years or the number of months
all the time rented just like with that
one it can be an or tape this can be a
nor T as well they refer to the same
thing how long it's been in this okay so
simple interest compound interest two
differences number one this one just
gives you the interest whereas this one
gives you the whole amount in the bank
account number two this is just straight
multiplying but this is trickier this is
got like index notation in it's a bit
okay